a new report suggests schools can and
should reopen
if they take certain precautions against
covid the report found that despite
more infectious covet variants schools
can still reopen
safely if they enforce protections like
mask wearing social distancing
increased ventilation and vaccinations
the study was written by the resolve to
save
lives initiative which works to prevent
epidemics former cdc director dr
tom frieden is the president and ceo of
the initiative good morning
thank you for joining us your first
interview you said live in 16 months
yeah
couple thousand from zoom and skype yes
we're glad to see you in person too tom
absolutely um but you know you say these
things have to happen for the schools to
reopen safely but how likely is it
to keep children social distance keep
those masks on
and have the proper ventilation that
you're talking about there are a few
things that we've learned in the past
year
one of them is that keeping schools open
for in-person learning is enormously
important
so our kids can learn so our economy can
grow so that we can not
exacerbate what are already huge
inequalities in our society
and that it's possible to do that we
can't underestimate this virus
especially
the delta variant which is highly
infectious but with a
layered approach it is possible to open
schools and keep
kids safe and we've also seen a number
of people talking about the requirements
whether it's the health care industry
do you think teachers should be required
to be
vaccinated to keep these children safe i
think we're going to see
more and more groups being mandated to
be vaccinated and also
sadly as the delta variant drives a big
increase in cases in the u.s it's going
to get we're going to see a lot more
cases
i think you're going to see more people
being willing to be vaccinated as well
you mentioned inequalities in society
they're inequalities in schools there
are a lot of overcrowded schools a lot
of them can't afford these updated
ventilation systems
what do those schools do there are
things you can do first off
vaccinate everyone who can be vaccinated
second masking masking is really
important and
it's painful to see the the states that
are banning mass
mandates in schools because that's going
to cost lives and that's going to cost
our kids
learning but you can also make sure that
you're
about finding cases quickly when they
occur and then taking action so they
don't spread widely in the schools
and for those few students and teachers
who may have underlying health
conditions
that are quite severe dialysis patients
or others you have an alternative
arrangement
the report also showed that kids under
the age of 10 consistently are very low
when it comes to getting covered cases
do you think tom that means that all
children should wear masks
even the ones even the little guys at a
certain age kids really can't
adhere to to wearing masks but any kid
who can should
and the more habit it gets the more
people get used to it and do it
what we know is that we have the tools
to stop covid
with masks and vaccination in particular
and it's painful to me as a physician to
see that we're not using them
we're not using them and if we did use
them much more effectively we'd save
more lives
and we'd get our kids back to school and
staying in school this fall
what about sports because a lot of the
outbreaks have occurred at sporting
events
there are things that need to be held
off in schools choirs for example
in places where covet is spreading
widely and we've seen in some contact
sports a lot of spread
you have to think about vaccination and
some activities need to be modified
when there's a lot of cove in the
community that's why it's up to all of
us to reduce covid
so our kids can learn safely so our
hospitals won't get overwhelmed and to
save lives and get our economy moving
what's your message we've said it over
and over to your blue in the face
you're turning a shade of blue tom by
the way right now because
we say the delta variant is like nothing
we've ever seen before that it's more
deadly that only the unvaccinated people
are really getting sick
how do we get this message across
without being judging
and condemning please don't
underestimate this virus
that could cost you or someone you love
their life
dr tom frieden thank you very much for
being with us this morning we appreciate
it it's great to see you again